red
hi can you hear me yep what's happening
man okay so uh hi Rich how you doing um
again never spoke to you oh just wanted
to say hi thanks um I had a quick
question not a very quick question but a
kind of quick question okay um so I'm
divorced about a year right now and
um my ex and I share 50 50 custody okay
so we're very very amicable you know the
kids split back and forth we have a very
back and forth situation and we started
getting close again and with your ex
with Max yeah close like in a romantic
sense or intimate sense uh intimate Yeah
by my house yeah okay so she's very
feminine the whole reason we got
divorced is because what you always talk
about today's station through a thousand
sessions you know that kind of thing it
wasn't really her it was really I would
say the Matrix more than anything else
it was really I got kind of sucked into
covid and everything and kind of lost
frame I mean I had frame at one point
but I seriously lost it and I want to
know what your thoughts are because you
always say don't date a single mother I
have three kids with her you always say
don't date a single mother but
in this kind of situation it's kind of
different well she's not really a single
mother I mean she's the mother of your
kids she's your ex-wife it's different
yeah so I mean your question is should I
should I get back together with an
ex-wife like why did you guys get
divorced why don't we start with that so
I I had a very very hard time with covet
because I lost a brother a younger
brother for covid and I kind of got like
upset by it let's just say that so her
reason for leaving wasn't entirely her
fault I I would I would put it more on
my end than on her end
okay so so what did she contribute to
the divorce so let me be a little more
specific you've taken ownership for your
[ __ ] awesome what did she contribute to
it you mean on what part she played in
it yeah I'm misunderstanding
so I was I'm the leader of the
relationship right okay I led the
relationship off a cliff that's how I
see it okay
and then she ended it because she didn't
feel
she didn't feel safe let's put it that
way okay I was very very upset after my
brother died let's just without getting
into too too worthy of the of a detail
about it but I was very very upset and I
understand why she left I do I do
understand it but I got past that look I
mean did you do anything outrageous like
were you violent did you physically you
know abuse her the kids because if I
lost my younger brother I would expect
my chick to to sort of deal with that
and be a shoulder for me to sort of
I don't want to say cry on and be a
little [ __ ] but I would expect a
certain amount of support
yeah I understand what you're saying I
actually agreed with that at the
beginning and then I kind of saw her
perspective
because I was not in the healthiest
place I'm not getting into like too much
detail about it just because you go and
bang anybody else when you guys were
going through all this [ __ ] no no
okay she's very conservative like that
so no
well look I mean I know a few people
that have gotten divorced and then
gotten back together with their wife but
they always get divorced again
afterwards I've never seen anybody
stick through it again
um if you manage to make it work please
call and let me know how you did it oh
certainly you know sure was the error
that they made
um it wasn't for it wasn't for a
situation like you know losing a younger
sibling and I don't know what the
details are and you're holding back on
some of it so it's very difficult for me
to offer much as far as feedback but
look
at the end of the day I mean if you want
to invite this woman back into your life
she is the mother of your children how
old are your kids
uh 10 7 4. they're still young they need
they need both their parents and it's
you know it's difficult for kids so if
you guys can make it work
um if she's going to enter your frame if
you're going to lead if you
um
know what you're doing now and you've
learned from the experience and she
doesn't bring red flags to the table
then give it a shot and let me know how
it works out I mean it's not ideal but I
understand look I mean you've got three
small children
um it's something to contemplate because
they matter
yeah of course I really appreciate it
36. I mean you could have kids still if
you wanted to but you've got three small
ones and it sounds like you've already
got an attachment the whole thing and
she didn't really leave for nefarious
reasons I mean yeah no I wasn't taking
it I'm into accounting or anything like
that the only thing I don't like is
conservative like that so yeah the only
thing I don't like Bud is that you know
when you're when your little brother
dies that that should not be a catalyst
to the divorce she should be able to
help you through the grieving portion
um so I don't know what happened you
you're not Dr you know putting on the
table for whatever reason you want I'll
let you figure that out I think that she
felt that I was dangerous I think that's
really what it was I wasn't but she got
the impression that was the case I think
that's really what it was at the end of
the day and the fact that I lost Freeman
I wasn't
why would she think that you're
dangerous I was very upset I was very
dangerous how like she was worried you
were going to shoot people up or
something or dangerous yeah that's I I
that's that's from in retrospect that's
what I found out but it wasn't obviously
the case I'm a very controlled person I
can control myself I'm not you know I'm
not a dangerous person I've never been
violent with anybody I've never I don't
get into conversations but I think she
thought that and so she like freaked out
and then just left it's a bit of a red
flag my friend okay I mean if a woman's
in your frame and she's totally about
you and the kids and the family
she should trust your judgment
she should know what you know right
that's just my take on it
okay thank you very much so marinate on
that for a little bit good luck man
thank you Happy New Year I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out